a half of the planet mosquitoes are more
than just a nuisance their bites
transmit parasites and viruses that kill
millions of people
each year one of them dengue virus
causes dengue fever it's often called
breakbone fever because patients feel
like the bones in their bodies are being
broken if you get secret dengue you can
have mild symptoms through to very
extreme symptoms where you're going to
have the internal bleeding shock and can
die so it's a big spectrum but if you
speak to anybody that's had bad dose of
dengue and I'll tell you it's one of the
worst things that happened to them in
their life dengue is considered the
world's fastest spreading tropical
disease it's cases have risen thirty
fold in the last 50 years
Sandia is like everywhere in the tropics
potentially 40 percent of the world's
population is at risk this year of
getting dengue that's a big number we're
talking about billions of people and
with the world's temperatures rising
dengue can spread out of the tropics
potentially reaching a further two
billion people by 2080
in Indonesia the total number of dengue
cases is second in the world it has been
proven very difficult to sort of get rid
of all the mosquitoes causing dinging in
the laboratories chemicals are
discovered for killing mosquitoes we've
tried very hard but still the mosquitoes
are around us so it needs something else
to combatting me
[Music]
eight years ago Scott O'Neal founded the
world mosquito program a non-profit
initiative running trials in 12
countries around the world one of them
here in Indonesia their sole aim is to
eradicate dengue in particular one
mosquito Aedes aegypti it is responsible
for transmitting between people a number
of diseases some of them obscure some of
them quite famous
so diseases like yellow fever dengue
chikungunya and most recently Zika and
the reason that this particular mosquito
Aedes aegypti is so good at being able
to cause these explosive epidemics is
because it's like the cockroach of the
mosquito world just like cockroaches it
likes to live with people it doesn't
live out in the forest in harmony with
nature or whatever
it lives in people's houses in concrete
jungles in cities and it bites people
maybe two or three times a day
and so often whole families get sick
with dengue because that one mosquito
bit everybody in that house within a
period of a couple of days
as soon as people discover that
mosquitoes transmit disease immediate
responses let's kill mosquitoes and the
thing is all those diseases are still
pretty well here and the reason is that
mosquitoes are really tough to cure and
if you realize where they breed you know
just in a tiny bit of water but you
realize that there are millions and
millions of places where these
mosquitoes are breeding and I thought of
killing every single one of them just
seems impossible
most researchers have focused on
genetically modifying mosquitoes or
trying to eradicate the species entirely
instead O'Neill's team is infecting
mosquitoes with bacteria not to kill
them
but to inoculate them it's a naturally
occurring bacteria called Wolbachia that
bacterium spreads into the mosquito
population and once the mosquitoes have
it they're unable to transmit the virus
between people you know I've had this
obsession for a long time of working on
Wolbachia it occurs naturally and around
60 to 70 percent of all insect species
all around the world so wherever you
live if you were to go outside
grab some insects out of the nearest
bush you'd likely find more often than
not that those insects naturally have
this bacteria called wolbachia the
mosquito that transmits all these
viruses to people doesn't have it when
we were able to put the war back here
into the mosquito and then we fed those
mosquitoes in laboratory virus we found
that just four back here by itself
without any fancy tricks would stop the
transmission of the viruses
well back here was stopping not just
dengue about yellow fever chikungunya
Zika mayoral a whole range of viruses
and so it was a major discovery but
introducing wolbachia bacteria to
disease-carrying mosquitoes like the ada
city isn't easy in fact the only way to
do it is to inject freshly laid mosquito
eggs with the bacterium this process
takes time O'Neal's team has spent more
than five years building their colony of
a few thousand mosquitoes but that was
the hard part
nature takes over this bacterium
transmits itself vertically from a
mother to her offspring so it gets
carried in the egg so what will backyard
does is that if it's in a female it will
be transmitted and so that female can
mate with other males that have will
back your males that done and she'll
produce eggs and those eggs will all
have fall back here the trick though is
the other way if a male has four back
yeah but the female doesn't have will
back here then she will lay eggs and all
their eggs will die the end result of
that is only females that have all back
are able to reproduce and so we'll back
here then spreads into the insect
population without having to be
infectious without having to jump from
one individual to another
in chalk Jakarta whenever you go to the
community and you ask do you know anyone
that had tanki before my guess is that
everyone will answer yes yeah because
it's it's it's so common and it still
created panic within the community
people often who live in transmission
areas live with a lot of fear about
dengue actually it's a family of viruses
that can be grouped into four groups and
unimaginative Lee
they're called dengue one two three and
four when you get infected say with
dengue one your body makes antibodies
against dengue one and so it's much
harder for you to then acquire dengue
one again a second time but those
antibodies don't protect you for dengue
two three or four but not only that
those antibodies will make it easier for
dengue two three and four to get into
your body and cause disease and actually
create potentially more severe disease
and so it's possible that you could get
dengue four times and each time you get
it you could potentially become more
sick and greater risk of dying
[Music]
jogjakarta is where the group is
conducting a major study they're
collecting data on how successful
Wolbachia is in stopping dengue
transmissions the first batch of
mosquitoes was released here in 2014 we
work with the community fire before we
release the mosquitoes to make sure that
they understand that what we are
targeting is is the virus not just
mosquitoes this project would have not
been possible without the community
understanding because the idea was like
controversy let's think about it for a
minute we're going to come in a bunch of
scientists and we're going to release
mosquitoes into the community and these
mosquitoes are going to bite you and all
you've heard for the last 50 years of
your life is that you have to kill
mosquitoes because they're dangerous you
would imagine the community would be
very cautious
I'd be cautious I'd want to know a lot
about what was going on and I think the
community is like that and we understand
that and we've really tried to address
that and and by doing that we've had
virtually no opposition communities are
a huge part of the project and the team
spends time explaining the science
behind their intervention but they're
also involving them in the mosquito
releases people take in the buckets with
mosquito eggs and take care of them
until the eggs hatch in this space
mosquitoes are being grown that contain
will back here so that we can collect
eggs off them and then as eggs will be
distributed into the community in job
Jakarta we're using human volunteers for
feeding and some of the researchers have
been bitten probably more than a million
times by mosquitoes with four vacuum or
for the sake of disease prevention the
team keeps monitoring how many
mosquitoes in the wild have wolbachia
and continues to release them until they
reach a certain threshold once this is
done the bacteria sustain themselves in
the mosquito population and the method
doesn't have to be repeated current data
shows around 70 percent reduction in
dengue cases in the areas where while
back here mosquitoes were released but
we think it's a big underestimate
because if you spend a little bit of
time in job Jakarta you'll notice that
everybody's on motorbikes traveling
everywhere and so it's possible that
they've gone out being bitten by a
mosquito and then come back in and go
and get counted as in the intervention
area
and it looks like you know everything
we've seen in the laboratory our
mathematical modeling everything is
coming together to suggest that we're
going to have a big impact on disease by
the end of this year the team's
Wolbachia method will cover about 3
million people around the world but they
want to reach at least a hundred million
by 2023 the ambition for our program is
big but the problem is huge eliminating
diseases is very challenging I think if
you look at polio today you can bring
polio down to very low levels but to do
the final elimination so there is no
more cases very challenging smallpox as
an example there aren't too many others
out there
[Music]
spreading Wolbachia mosquitoes around
half of the planet is a monumental task
it would require a huge injection of
funding and a coordinated effort of
governments but the three billion people
at risk of such dangerous viruses
motivates the team to keep fighting
there's an obsessive nature to the work
that we do and I think that sits behind
a lot of science have an idea and then
to really hold on to it and then work
and what I can work on work until we're
successful and so my hope would be that
we could eliminate a dengue at some
point
[Music]
you
[Music]